we've already seen that when a neuron is
in its resting state there is a voltage
difference across the membrane and so
and these diagrams right over here this
right over here is the membrane that
right over is the membrane this right
over here is the inside of the neuron
and this right over here is the outside
that's the outside and of course this is
the outside this is the outside as well
so if you had a voltmeter measuring the
potential difference across the membrane
so if you took this this voltage minus
this voltage right over here the voltage
referring this and that you would get
negative let's say for the sake of
argument let's say you would measure it
would average about negative 70
millivolts so this is in millivolts
negative 70 so that's negative 70
negative 70 millivolts and I'll do it
actually for both of these graphs we're
going to use both of these to describe
slightly different or actually quite
different scenarios and you could have
another voltmeter out here in yellow and
that's a little further out but that's
also as that's also going to register
negative 70 millivolts now let's make
something interesting happen let's say
that for some reason let's say that the
membrane becomes permeable to sodium so
sodium just starts flooding through it's
going to flood through for two reasons
one it is a positive ion it's more
positive on the outside than the inside
so positive charge will want to flood in
and the other reason why it will want to
flood in is because there's a higher
concentration of sodium on the outside
than on the inside so just across its
constant just it'll just go down its
concentration gradient the reason why we
have a higher concentration gradient on
the sodium on the outside than the
inside we've already seen is because of
the sodium potassium pump but anyway so
you're going to have this increase
you're going to really have the spike
and positive charge flowing in and then
what's cool what are going what's going
to be the dynamic then inside the neuron
well if you have all this positive
charge right over here the other
positive charge in the neuron is going
to want to get away from it it's going
to want to get away from it other
positive charge is going to want to get
away from it and so the positive charge
is going and this is not just in the
rightward Direction is really going to
be in all directions in all directions
the positive
they're going to want to get away from
each other so this one's going to move
that way and then that's going to make
that one want to move that way which is
going to make that one we want to move
that way so if we let some time pass
what's the voltage going to look like on
this blue voltmeter well after some time
because more and more positive charges
are trying to get away from these other
ones right over here is the
concentration of these parts positive
charges spread out
you're going to see the voltage start to
increase you're going to see the voltage
start to increase and then as they fully
get spread out then it might return it
might return to something of an
equilibrium and then as we if we go a
little bit further down the neuron as
you go a little bit further down then
you're on a little more time will pass
before you see a voltage increase but
because this thing is getting spread out
across more and more distance that the
effect is going to be more limited
you're not going to see as much of a
bump in the voltage over here then you
saw over here and this type of spread of
I guess you could say a signal is called
electrotonic spread let me write that
down
electro electro Tonique spread or this
is a spread of an electro tonic
potential electrotonic potential so
there's a couple of characteristics here
one it's passive this part that we drew
right here this isn't the electrotonic
spread what happened the electrotonic
spread is what happens after that once
you have this high concentration here
the fact that a few moments later you're
going to have a higher concentration of
positive charge here and a few moments
later a higher positive concentration
here this is a passive phenomenon so
this thing right over here it is passive
and it also dissipates the signal gets
weaker and weaker the further and
further you get out because this stuff
just gets further and further spread out
so it's passive and it dissipates and it
dissipates now let's play out the
scenario again but let's also throw in
some voltage-gated ion channels right
over here so let's say this right over
here that I'm drawing let's say this is
a voltage-gated let's say this is a
voltage-gated sodium channel
and this one right over here so this is
a sodium channel sodium channel let's
say it opens let's say it opens at
negative 55 millivolts so let's see that
would be right around right around there
so that is when it opens at negative 55
millivolts let me draw that threshold
there and let's say it closes let's say
it closes at positive 40 millivolts so
it closes at positive 40 millivolts
right over there I'm just trying to show
the threshold and let's say we also have
some potassium let's say we have a
potassium channel - right over here
right over here and let's say so this is
a potassium channel the infamous leaky
potassium channels which are the the
true reason why we have this voltage
difference across a across the membrane
but this potassium channel let's say it
opens when this one closes so it opens
just for the sake of argument these
aren't going to be the exact numbers but
give you the idea at positive 40
millivolts and let's say it closes at
negative at negative 80 millivolts so
that one opens up here and then it
closes and it closes it closes down here
now what is going to happen well just
like we saw before so let's let's let's
just let's let our positive charge flood
in here at the left side of our at the
left side of this the left side of this
of this neuron I guess we could say and
then because of electrotonic spread
you're going to have the put a little
bit later you're going to have the
potential between the potential across
the membrane at this point is going to
start to become less negative the
potential difference is going to become
less negative just like we saw right
over here so it's going to become less
negative but it's not just going to be a
little bump and then go back down
because what happens right when the
potential hits negative 55 millivolts
well then it's going to trigger this
it's going to trigger the opening of
this sodium channel so this sodium
channel is going to open because the
voltage
not high enough and so you're going to
have sodium flood in again sodium flood
in again and so what's that going to do
well that's going to spike up spike up
the voltage so it's going to look
something like that's going to keep
flowing in keep flowing keep flowing in
the voltage is going to get more and
more positive because remember this is
going to be flowing in for two reasons
one there's just a there's just more
char it's more positive outside than the
inside so it's going to go across a
voltage gradient or go down the voltage
gradient but also are the electro
electro potential gradient but also
there's a higher put concentration of
sodium out here than there is in here
because of the sodium potassium pump and
so it'll also want to go down its
concentration gradient so it's just
going to keep flowing in even past the
point at which you have no electro no
voltage gradient but because of the
concentration gradient going to keep
going but then as you get to positive 40
millivolts this channel is going to
close so that's going to stop flooding
in and you also have the potassium
channel opening and the potassium
channel now you're more positive on the
inside than the outside at least locally
right over here and so now you're going
to have this positive positively charged
potassium ions want to get out want to
get out from this pot from this positive
environment and so the voltage is going
to get more and more negative it's going
to go beyond a neutral because potassium
is going to want to go down not just not
just its voltage gradient it's going to
do that while it's positive on the
inside and negative on the outside or
more positive on the inside than it is
on the outside but there's also it'll
also want to go down its concentration
gradient there's more Pratap there's a
higher concentration of potassium on the
inside than on the outside because of
the sodium potassium pump so it'll just
keep the potassium will just keep going
out and out and out and out and then a
negative 80 millivolts the potassium
channel closes and then we can get back
to we can get back to our equilibrium
state we could get back to our
equilibrium state now why is this
interesting well we had the electrotonic
spread up to this point but the signal
would just keep dissipating and keep
dissipating if you get further if you
get far enough it would be very hard to
notice that signal and so what this
essentially just did is
boosted the signal again it just boosted
the signal and now a few moments later
if you were to measure if you were to
measure the potential difference because
these things are trying to get away from
each other again once again you have
electrotonic spread if you try if you
were to measure the potential difference
across this yellow across the membrane
where this yellow voltmeter is then
you're going to have so where that
yellow one is before it had a just a
little dissipated bump here but now it's
going to have quite a nice it's going to
have quite a nice bump and if you
actually had another voltage-gated
channel right over here then that would
boost it again and so this this this
this kind of very active boosting of the
of of the of the of the voltage this is
called an action potential action action
potential you could view this as the
boosting of the signal the signal
spreading electrotonic electrotonic
spread then you trigger a channel a
voltage-gated channel then that boosts
the signal again and as we'll see the
neuron uses a combination just the way
we described it here in order to spread
a signal in order for it to have the
signal spread but in order to be also in
order to see the spread passively but
then to boost it so that the signal can
cover over long distances